[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] chapter and verse. Sometimes
[inaudible] born to run.
Won't commit Springsteen for a Spiller Lang it can pull me down for a
stocking. Your first artist is.
Being hailed all over the country is one.
Of the most important new talents of the seventies.
A warm welcome
to Bruce Springsteen.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Good. Thank you. It is my birthday.
[Inaudible] do you, do you have a birthday routine?
Do you have something that you always do when you.
Yeah, I do actually, uh, we live close to the beach,
so I'll usually go to the beach. I take a swim and I have,
we have a big family in the area where we live.
We've got about 50 or 60 people, so we all meet down the beach.
We have a little Tiki bar, we set up the drinks,
we get the music playing and we have a little beach party,
usually around September 23rd is it's perfect.
You know, it's perfect. So, uh,
we kind of do we do that mostly pretty much every, every year. That's that's my,
you know, cheeseburgers, hot dogs is fun.
You're you're here with your memoirs now. So
it's not like a four hour concert this time. It's.
Very funny.
And reading it.
It strikes me that the past is very much present in your
life and everybody's life. Yeah. But you have such a fantastic man.
That's why I wrote it now, before I forgot.
[Inaudible] um, and you started,
you started out quite early with music and you,
you were very determined, determined from a young age. Uh,
and actually I understand that you wanted to be,
uh, you wanted to replace Jagger in the rolling stones. You have this dream.
I had a dream about it a couple of times. Yeah.
That's what I used to work in front of my mirror.
I used to try to get all Jagger's moves and I put the stones records on and I
lip sync to the stones records. And so I had a fantasy that he would,
he'd be in Asbury one night and I don't know, he'd come down with the,
with the cold. He couldn't make the show and they needed somebody really badly.
And it was a very pimple faced boy in the front row. And we need that.
She had now, you know, so, and the audience went wild.
I had that dream too. Except it was you
come up really? You wouldn't want that. I promise you, uh,
tell me, um, was it,
was there a moment in your career when you realized
that working with a band you had to be in charge?
Well, I had a lot of experience before I signed a record contract.
I was, I'd gotten around a lot.
I'd driven across the country and back with the band several times.
Uh, we drew thousands of people to our live shows with no record.
I was probably 19, 20 years old.
So I had a lot of experience with small unit democracy.
And I found out didn't work out that it didn't work that well, small unit,
it's very difficult, very difficult to make work in a,
in rock and roll framework. So, uh, when I signed my record deal,
I knew that I wanted to be a solo act,
but I also missed the band cause I played in bands my whole life. So,
uh, I had my guys from the neighborhood. So I signed my contract. I said, well,
I want to kind of call the shots, but I need my, my,
my, my men around me and my men and women, you know? So, uh,
um, that was kind of how it played out.
I put the band together pretty early after I signed my record deals and I was a
lead because a lot of people don't realize those things till it's too late,
until you're much later on in your career. And, and you know, you see,
I mean the rock and roll bins is very strange business.
Imagine that you are in high school and,
you know, three other people, four other people.
And then you work with those people for the entire rest of your life.
Those four people from high school, wherever you go and whatever you do,
you work with them for the entire rest of your life.
There's no other business where that happens except the music.
So you better be very close friends.
Yeah. How, how, how have they dealt with this lack of democracy through,
through the years? Pretty well, everybody
[inaudible].
Yeah, they they've done very well. So that smoothed out a lot of the bumps,
you know? Uh,
but there's still a lot of give and take and there's a lot of opinions gathered
and, and, uh, it's, it's, it's still very much a collective.
I want to go back. I want to go back to your childhood. Uh,
you write a lot about it and it's it's you, you, you,
you described two holes, really. You grew up in two homes,
it's your parents' home and your grandparents are just near each other.
Yeah, that was very difficult to, we had an unusual set up as a child.
I lived in a house with my grandparents and my parents from my first,
first six years of my life. There was the nuns convent, the church,
the priest directory, the Catholic school, my aunt and my cousin,
my aunt and my uncle and my cousins,
my grandmother up the street and across the street,
my Italian aunt and my Irish uncle.
And this was all within the space of these chairs, right?
So it was a very close knit neighborhood. And,
uh, I grew up through most of my young life in that setting
raised by primarily the Irish people we ever Irish
Italian, uh, then around six or seven, my mother took me to,
there was a half house that we lived in with my parents.
It was very difficult because I,
I really grown up in my grandparents home and they'd done a lot of parenting.
And it was, you sort of get, I got really pulled apart at that young age,
you know, but.
They, they, they did the loss of parenting you said,
but it was really a loss of freedom for, it was too much. Yeah.
Understand when I was five or six, I was staying up till 3:00 AM, you know,
and when I'd get up at three in the afternoon, and, uh,
that explains why, the minute I got out of school,
I found a job where I sleep till three and a half and I stay up till
3:00 AM. Couldn't have been a coincidence.
But how do you think seriously, that that affected your personality? That,
that.
It made me a little crazy, you know, made me a little crazy. Um,
that's too much freedom for a child, you know? So, uh,
but then you go in search of it for the rest of your life. You know,
you go in search of sort of this very boundaryless existence, and there's no,
there's no,
there's no greater business where the boundaries are very
fuzzy and hazy than the music business. You, you.
Had a nickname, uh, which wasn't Blinky.
That was bad, man. Well, I got, I was very nervous child. I was very,
very nervous. And when I was very anxious when I was young,
because I knew things weren't operating correctly at home.
So I used to chew my knuckles into stones and,
and I've had a thing where I blinked, you know,
who knows hundreds of times a minute, you know, it was just, it was,
I was a very neurotic kid, very nervous.
And this was because at home, in your parents' house,
it was like an atmosphere of.
Some of it's genetic. You know, we,
we kind of had a very neurotic and anxious family that got passed
down, particularly on the Irish side.
So some of it was just there and the rest of it was just some of the tensions of
the household and, uh, uh, you know,
you're young and you're small and it's, you don't know how.
Well, what was it? I mean, we were talking about your dad here. What,
what was it? Was he passive aggressive or, or was it also outbursts?
It was very difficult. My father was very ill. So, um, it,
which showed up quite a bit later in life, but,
but it was there when he was young, but now no one really recognized, you know?
So it was,
it was the day where no one had any psychiatric knowledge or no one
understood, uh, uh, manic depressive illness or anything like that. So,
so everybody just was a child,
he assumed was normal and whatever there's a problem you assume is your fault.
And you simply try to make it better, which you can't,
and it turns you into a nervous wreck, you know, but, uh, uh,
my dad was a good guy, but he, he struggled with a very serious illness.
He was diagnosed later, later in life. Yeah.
Paranoid schizophrenia. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
I, I wonder, did you,
as a child try to try to please him, or did you go up against him?
Well, as a child, you try to please, you know, you, you, you, I mean,
your parents are gods in your home. You, what do you have?
All you have is your little set of rooms and, and, you know,
they're everything. So you, you, you try to play then of course,
once you get to be a teenager, it's a little bit different, you know, you,
you start butting heads. And, uh, so we had a long period of,
uh, uh, where we were separated quite a bit. And we were,
we bumped heads very hard when I was a teenager. And, uh,
but it was a time of tremendous generational upheaval. Also,
this was 1966 and 67,
where things were going on that generation.
My parents were how old were they? I was, I was 16. They were 35.
I'm still very young, but the generation gap was enormous at that time.
So could not, they couldn't understand what I was going through and, and,
and truth vice versa. I didn't understand their lives very well either.
You know, you don't,
you're still too young to really recognize your parents as human beings. And,
uh, uh, you know, so it's, it makes for a very,
very rough household.
Did you ever, when you go to his dog, he knows later, did you ever talk,
talk about it? Was it, was it something you can talk about?
No. Uh, my,
my father was very, not a talkative person,
which he was throughout his entire life that never changed. Uh,
and so we had to communicate, in other words, I communicated through my music.
I wrote a lot of songs about my dad, you know, and I also believe that I,
I modeled myself on my father and my father was a blue collar working
class guy. He was kinda, he was kind of beefy and big. And,
and I think when I, when I went to work,
I kind of put his clothes on and I chose to write about
that, that, that part of my life and that part of our lives together.
And it was a way of trying to communicate with them was also a way of trying to
honor him was a way of trying to probably seek out his love.
I'm sure. And so this was how we communicated. And my only,
uh, I, I never heard anything. I'd take the records to the house.
Never heard anything, bring them over, play, never heard anything.
Then at the very end of his life, I said, Hey dad, you know,
what's your favorite songs? You know, he goes, Oh, the ones about me.
That's true.
[inaudible].
Music. Music was, I had a feeling.
It was in the Italian side of my family.
They all played the piano a little bit and sang. Um, but I was like,
everybody else, I, I saw Elvis on television and, and it,
it just rattled me.
And then the Beatles came in 64 when I was 14, which was the perfect age.
You were ripe for the picking, you know, you were,
didn't quite know who you were looking for, something to identify with,
looking for something you could do.
So you could stand yourself when you look in the mirror.
And all of a sudden there it was, there's four guys.
There's a bunch of women. They're screaming at them.
Well, how do I learn to do that job? So
do you see yourself, do you see yourself as,
as a songwriter first and foremost, or a guitarist or a senior, or.
That was, I was young. I was, you know,
the fastest guitar in town. You know, I started out as a guitarist.
And so that was, I was a gunslinger and, uh, uh,
did that for a long time, built a big rep as a guitar player.
And then I started to sing a little bit,
and then I built a big rep as a front man, but I, when I looked around,
I was very, very good,
but I could see guys that could play guitar as well or better.
See guys had sang as well or better. So I said,
I really concentrated on my writing because your writing,
you have a chance to develop a very singular voice,
a voice that's your own comes out of your roots, comes out of the town.
You came from, comes out of the people that, that you came from.
And that was my, that was my goal. You know, I wanted to tell my story,
my parents' story, my town's story.
And ultimately I wanted to tell your story.
So I really concentrated on developing an original voice through my writing.
And part of that,
I didn't part of this project is it's kind of
describing if I understand you, right?
The landscape between the American dream and the American reality what's
happening there.
I took that on as sort of my,
my job as I got older, I just naturally wrote that kind of music.
First of all, you know, I mean, you know,
in America, you're taught
anybody can go there. You know, anybody can you've got it.
But at the same time, I bumped into the rat with my parents.
I saw them struggle very, very, very,
very difficultly for the tiniest little slice of what people call the American
dream. So I said, okay, this is, it's a lot harder than it looks, you know?
And I just took that as something that I wanted to write about, you know,
it was also a way of,
of criticizing the place I came from while,
while still feeling a sense of pride, you know? So I said, well,
I'm going to try and measure that distance between what's re what's reality.
What's the dream cause that's what the country is struggling towards every day.
Uh, and the better we're doing that, the better as a people we are,
but it, it's very difficult.
And it's a lot of baby steps is as anyone in,
in government knows, you know, it's uh, and, uh,
but it, it was,
it made for a satisfying and rich writing stuff.
Checked,
but looking at America today and what's happening this fall
with the election. Yes. Uh, the current were from Europe.
It's very hard to understand what's happening.
So how would you explain that for,
for Sweden and the region people? I mean, it's, it's very.
How would I explain it speaking to a Swedish or Norwegian person?
[Inaudible] I don't, I can't find in any of your songs, I can,
I can find a lot of characters, but I can't find Donald Trump.
That would be, you'd have to search out the Carnie Barker, you know, the, uh,
the fraud, but, uh, it's, uh, uh, it's very difficult.
I think, you know, there are certain,
we have certain problems in the United States because of the tremendous
inequality of the wealth distribution that makes for ripe,
ripe ground for demagoguery. And he comes along and he has a very simple,
a simple answer to all these very, very complex problems, uh,
and is telling people some of the people, the things that they want to hear,
if you're very uncomfortable by the Browning of America,
while we're going to build a wall and keep all those people out,
if you're frightened from T Ravel,
we're just going to keep all those people out. Uh,
if you're worried about your job, we're going to bring all your jobs back,
you know, so this is basically his campaign saying it,
like I'm saying it here, you know, so,
but if you've struggled and if you've suffered and you haven't gotten that piece
of the pie, or you're just struggling to keep your family going,
it can be someone saying is a very, very compelling argument. It can be. And,
and, you know, there's, it's very difficult to deal with the complexities of,
of, of governance. And, and, uh,
if someone tell you to wait or be patient it's, so there's,
it's just a rich environment for,
for unfortunately for a demagogue. And, uh,
while he's, it's almost too high,
too high of a title to place it, it's, it's, it's, the absurdity is, is, is,
is beyond cartoon. Like, you know, but, um,
he's gotten close enough, so it can make you nervous. You know,
I don't think he's gonna win, but, uh,
even him running is a great embarrassment for you're an American.
[Inaudible].
I have done my best, best to avoid that happening.
We were talking about control, um,
and you're in control and you are, you are,
I know you're not happy with the word, but you are the boss. Uh
[inaudible] but, uh, in, in your, in your memoirs,
uh, there is one episode where you lose control and that's,
that's in Gothenburg.
What was happening there? We didn't know.
I, I don't remember. I think I remembered in the book.
All I remember was smashing a guitar with him.
And that's not you. I mean, that's not your style. Is it.
Within inches of Jon Landau? My manager's head, unfortunately. And,
uh,
I think I was young and I was just starting to play these very large venues.
And I felt an enormous amount of stress to not lose my
contact with my audience.
And I was used to a certain sort of intimacy with my audience,
and I was unsure if I could bring that along and present that.
And in venues of that sort.
Swedish press had printed a picture of your hotel bed.
That was something well done.
The tabloid news in Sweden is very intense, you know,
and which I found out when I was married and we went through Stockholm and,
and we were pursued quite intensely. And, uh,
then when we left,
there was simply a picture of our hotel bed in the newspapers.
So I did wonder if this is going to go on for the rest of my life.
And of course, people get bored quickly and move on. So it didn't.
Maybe sleep deprivation as well.
Since we talked about the Arianna Huffington was here to sleep. Yeah.
Do you have ever had that sleep deprivation?
I sleep pretty well, but I dream really wildly, you know,
my dreams are like a house party or going on. I mean, there's, it's just,
I dream every night, very intensely.
I sleep for about eight or nine hours. I like to sleep. Perfect. But.
So do you write down your dreams?
I used to, but I stopped doing it, you know, I mean,
I used to write them down and I go in and I'd tell a guy and he'd tell me what I
was thinking. And he was, he was right very often, but, uh,
uh, I should probably write them down again. I've gotten out of the habit, but,
uh, they're very cool.
You, you, you also write very,
you're very open about, about not only your father's problems,
but your own problems, your own.
Ran, ran in the family. So.
Maybe it's more like, it's more like a depression you write about isn't it.
Family members who really suffered through it. You know, I don't know,
half a dozen probably, you know,
just on the Irish side have had a lot of different mental issues.
It was just something that was in our blood, you know?
So the piece of it got ahold of me and,
and I've had to deal with it throughout my life a little bit, but, uh, uh,
you know, it was a lot of psychopharmacology. It really helps out a lot. Uh,
and, uh, you know, I did the talk therapy and that's actually, that's,
I've done it for a long, long time, 30 years or so.
38 Years with the therapist.
[inaudible].
What did I learn.
With the same type of therapist.
Or, Oh, I had one guy that died on me already.
[Inaudible].
He literally went through his death trying to figure me out, you know,
then I went through another guy. So.
Tell me about that first time being Bruce Springsteen, very famous person,
because you were a 30 years ago and you go into that office.
I mean, it's.
You know, well, their job is to see, see through all that, you know, of course.
And, uh, I mean, I didn't ask the guy if he was a fan, you know,
I just want, wanted to cry, you know, there was no, there wasn't any,
there wasn't any talk about my records or anything. So, uh,
um, uh, when, once you get there where you you're going there,
those things don't matter in much.
This is something that comes and goes in your life as it does. Um,
is it, is it possible to describe how it feels? I mean,
how that darkness is?
Well, it's just, everything goes blank, you know, it's like, you're,
you're just done. It's, it's, it's, uh,
you can't get out of bed and everything is,
is, it's a very distinct,
you have a very distorted picture of your life and those around you, you know?
So, uh, um, and it sapped a lot of your energy,
amazingly, not when I played her, when I recorded, for some reason,
those things remained on touch, you know, but, uh,
for your family life and for your home life,
it takes a lot of your energy and confuses things quite a bit. But, um,
you know, you,
you work your way through it and we figure it out as best as you can.
And I was lucky, you know, Patty was, you know, my wife was very,
very helpful and, uh, she's been very patient. Yeah, very, she was very,
just always great with spotting it when it was, you know, you're not doing well,
you know, you think about, you know, think about what's going on.
So she was very helpful, very, very helpful.
Churchill suffered from depression. And he called, it said.
The black dog, the black dog.
The need by black dog or something, it would.
The black dog. Yeah, it's true. That was a good policy. Good name for it.
Good. Thank God for, for good medicine.
Thank God for drugs. That's really
[inaudible].
I must ask you, when you, you, you, you came to Scandinavia this summer and you,
you, uh, gave several concerts and, uh,
you're famous also for, uh,
for these concerts going on so long.
And now this is your birthday. You you're 67 years old.
Let's [inaudible].
They need to become, the concerts will need to become shorter.
That's a good point, you know, uh, I mean, uh,
it's nice for yourself. That's what I'm saying. I don't know.
You know, they've actually gotten longer as I've gotten older, so, uh, yeah.
Well, why do you do that? And I said, I have no idea.
Yeah. It's a little out of my control. I, I, I don't watch the clock.
Um, I go out there until something happens and if it feels good,
then you want to stay, you know, and we've had,
we have incredible audiences in Sweden and in Norway, I mean, we have just,
this is their home away from home there, you know? So it's, it's,
you always want to be at your very best when you're, when you're there. So, um,
you know,
it shows in Gothenburg this summer were just spectacular and,
but it's a deep home feeling when I, when I go there now, you know,
I really feel, uh, it's, it's, it's my place, you know?
So, uh, but why didn't I play some I, I'm not sure. You know,
I mean, I've,
I've spent a lot of time asking the doctors about that.
Well, nobody's complaining here. Just be sad,
but I, I, I'm thinking you, you, we want you to last long, you know,
I'll let you know when I'm in trouble and I have one last question.
Did you ever get to play with the stones?
I did. I did. Yeah.
[Inaudible].
And it was, uh, it was better than my dream. It was, it was, uh,
it was in a little rehearsal studio. It was just the, you know,
just the guys in the band and myself, and,
and it just threw me completely back to being in a garage with my guys in the
early days. And it was, it was pretty wonderful. It was pretty wonderful.
So thank you. Thank you.
[Inaudible].